i mean if if you're allowed to tell us
you don't have to but
if it's too personal it's fine but how
if you did you ever try and date
like after or during the period and like
how was that when you're like not during
it because like you know it's kind of
hard to be like hey i'm going to work
there are a lot of actors like who are
dating like who are in a relationship
but i didn't know how
they coped with it you know it's a bit
like hey yeah hi honey i'm gonna have
sex
and they hated dating actors
so they understand the pain of like your
significant other
doing the job right right and some of
them like dated
actors too and like it was always like
they were always fighting because of
that
yeah yeah wow so like how small is the
industry do you did you know like a lot
of people
working in the industry like like when
you worked with other actors or
actresses did you already know them
personally or was it something was it
like some someone you met on the day
actors like most i've never got to know
them personally
maybe just on social media they try to
i don't think they're nicer
like i don't know not compared to
anybody that's a company
no male actors they want
after like a request they can make a
request like i want this actor
on this set that kind of thing right so
that's why some of them are like
obviously sucking up to you right now
okay yeah but in a good way you know
just like me like bringing all those
gifts
you know no no obviously
yeah uh because actors are all free runs
this
okay they can get hired at any time like
they don't have management companies
behind you oh they're they're getting
kids
you know guys oh wow oh okay and their
payments are lower
than us that's how it is i think in the
western yeah because in our mind like
men are like happy in the industry okay
whereas women sometimes like they have
to do this
right yeah right so basically you have
you the all the women have the power to
choose who they want to work with
oh okay so you got you got to be good at
socializing and uh making network
connections if you're a male porn
actress then
male 1 won't actually have to do more
like they usually just
oh i saw you on twitter like you know
they just check
our name and like do some research
before yeah well we very
got to know them i guess it's like real
life isn't it just yeah if you want to
be associated with someone just don't be
a dick
yeah just don't be an [ __ ] and you'll
probably be associated with them yeah
i wanted to know actually and i know
this is like kind of gonna get a bit
weird
but like you know how there's a type of
jav and this is
only in jav but it's like the creepy
dude
right like like you know we we call we
call it the ugly bastard i think
in other words i've always wanted to
know
like well first of all have you ever
done anything like that like in that
genre and if you have
like what what are the actors like in
real life because i've always wanted to
know right because it's like 50 year old
men looking
yeah yeah yeah and they like and they
purposely have to like act creepy right
yeah
just like we actually need them
it's not amazing but directors and
staff members producers say because the
people watching
people can relate to that oh my god
it's true it's true i've always heard
this but i never thought i was like no
that can't be it
people can identify with them either
you know beautiful always beautiful
women yeah of course sometimes
most of it is the ugly guy it's like a
meme in our circles where
i imagine though did you just get to
that point where you're like you don't
care it's just like work
or or were you like oh god okay i didn't
even
hate any of them yeah i was like i was
so
well there must be some days right when
you rock up and you're like oh this
uh yeah i mean i'm good at acting i
guess like he looked way better
that head shot was from 20 years ago
don't lie he definitely uses the snow
app on his headshot
actually guys like who's thinking who
lacks confidence in their body
they're actually nicer to you like they
appreciate you more okay that makes so
much sense yeah
if i wasn't an actor you're giving some
people a lot of confidence right now
that's me i can [ __ ] good
i can be an ugly bastard you're looking
like a famous actor they tend to be just
like [ __ ]
yeah yeah it's just like whatever i can
do
i'm handsome you're happy with that
right kind of thing
i mean wow to think that the more
handsome you are the more egotistical
yeah who would have thought to think
that ugly bastards are uh
like wanted commodity in the foreign
industry
after one actor i think who been around
in the industry more than 10 years so
he's obviously our experienced one right
yeah and
he's um good looking now
he's like if i do this then you're gonna
skirt
what what what
like if i do that then you're gonna come
really
no he won't he's just overly confident
come
come come come come no no no no no
oh my god no i would if someone said
that to me like oh i have to [ __ ] you
now
like you said that to me are you serious
yeah like what is like a
mariachi band like yeah what the [ __ ]
going on
oh my god could you imagine if it was
the opposite
if like you're about to like have sex
with a girl and she's like
when i do that oh my god she's all over
me i'm just like
we'll see like [ __ ] i mean i
can actually imagine that with some
people though
that's some ideal relationship so that's
the whole dom thing right it's like
they're like oh my god yes